Mr. Sawyer, is your family enjoying their stay?
Very much so.
They're shocked you gave us the entire floor.
After your security assessment,...
...what do you think of the building?
With all due respect, he is a glorified security guard.
Please.
The Pearl is the tallest, most advanced building in the world.
You've built a vertical city.
But you brought with it every single safety and security challenge...
...that I could think of.
We thought this floor was empty.
So did I.
Not only have you brought them all indoors...
...but you've trapped them 240 floors in the air.
No one really knows what would happen if things go wrong.
But I'm just a glorified security guard, so...
...what the hell do I know anyway?
What's going on?
The 96th floor is on fire.
You're going to be just fine, I promise you that.
No, no, no, no, no, no!
Daddy!
Tell me, how much do you love your family?
If we're gonna get out of here,...
...you're gonna have to tell me the truth.
There's a reason why they chose this building.
My family is the only thing that matters to me right now.